Der SCP-Paderborn schickt sich an, das Aufstiegsrennen in der 2. Liga mächtig aufzuwirbeln. Der SSV Ulm hingegen will nach 2 Aufstiegen in Folge erstmal einfach nur die Klasse halten. Darüber spreche ich im Rasenfunk in der Liga Tour mit SCP-Fan Ramona Kleibaumhüter und Sportjournalistin Nadine Voigt von der Südwestpresse.
Let's go!
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Russis zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kurt aus dem Bewühm.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Und nicht nur irgendeine Liga, sondern die 2. Bundesliga der Männer, die bekanntermaßen spannendste Liga der Welt, engste Liga der Welt, die beste 2. Liga der Welt. Ich bin der beste Host der Welt, nein nicht ganz, aber ich bin Marc Schwitzky, ich bin der Host für diese Sendung. Ich übernehme jetzt wieder im Wechsel natürlich mit Eva diese 2. Liga-Tour vom Rasenfunk. Und freue mich sehr, dass sie eingeschaltet hat. Wir reden heute zum einen über den SC Paderborn, aber auch über den SSV Ulm. Und das mache ich selbstverständlich nicht alleine. Über den SCP rede ich heute mit Ramona Kleibaumhüter. Grüß dich, Mona!
Wenn wir jetzt beim Thema Zukunft gerade sind, dann lass uns natürlich auch gerne auf das Saisonende gucken und darüber hinaus, wie jeder will in der Liga bleiben. Gleichzeitig wird sich Ulm bewusst sein, dass das mit den Bedingungen einfach schwer wird. Also, wie erpicht ist man auf den Klassenerhalt und wie plant man mittelfristig seine Zukunft? Wo will man denn ungefähr sich einpendeln in den nächsten Jahren? Gibt es da Angaben zu?
Ja, also, so überstehend ist natürlich der Klassenerhalt. Das ist ja irgendwo auch klar. Wenn man jetzt in der Liga steht, dann werden wir das auch halten. Ich sag jetzt mal, ich bin da auch ganz guter Dinge. Reden wir in einem halben Jahr noch mal drüber. Ja. Aber auch das wurde vor, dass es so relativ klar kommuniziert. Da würde ich auch einen Geschäftsführer August Hiele zitieren. Ulm muss verstehen, dass der Profifußball auch weitergeht, wenn man aus der 2. Liga absteigen würde. Dann geht man in die 3. Liga und kann auch da profitabel wirtschaften, kann einen guten Job machen und so weiter. Ich glaube, da spricht einfach diese große Sorge oder diese große Angst in Ulm an, die einfach aus der Vergangenheit herrührt mit diesen drei Insolvenzen. Ja, dass man einfach Bedenken hat, dass das alles so auf einem soliden Fundament steht, wirtschaftlich und so weiter. Und im Prinzip ist das schon auch mit, neben dem Sportlichen, natürlich das große Ziel, dass man sagen muss, man will wirtschaftlich solide dastehen und niemand soll hier irgendwie Angst haben, dass es in einer 4. Insolvenz enden würde. Und da bin ich aber ja auch guter Dinge, auch mit Blick auf das, was in den vergangenen Jahren passiert ist und wie da gearbeitet wurde, dass da jetzt schon ein Team am Werk ist, dass das in die richtigen Fahnen hängt.
Als ich gerade noch über Themen außerhalb des Platzes bei Ulm nachgedacht habe, sind mir ehrlich gesagt natürlich nicht so viele eingefallen, aufgrund der wenigen Berührungspunkte in den letzten Jahren. Ein Thema, da hoffe ich gar nicht, dass ich dich damit überrolle, ist aber natürlich schon die Tendenzen in der Fanszene. Ich glaube, das hat in den letzten Jahren ein Stück weit Schlagzeile gemacht, dass der SSV Ulm Probleme haben soll mit Hooligans, mit übergriffigem Verhalten im Blog. Kannst du das eventuell ein wenig ausführen und auch sagen, wie der Verein damit umgeht? Ich will jetzt kein riesiges Fass aufmachen, aber ich glaube, dass man das immer ansprechen sollte, wenn man die Chance dazu hat.
Ich glaube, dass da in den vergangenen Jahren etwas überspitzt darüber berichtet wurde. Das kann ich jetzt auch aus meiner Perspektive als Journalistin sagen. Ich glaube, dass das Thema vielleicht auch von Medien und so weiter oder ausentstehenden Personen, die jetzt vielleicht in Ulm nicht vor Ort sind, größer gemacht wurde als es ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass Ulm eine größere– ich sage jetzt links oder rechtsextremes– Hooligan, was auch immer ein Problem hat, als andere Vereine. Ich glaube aber, dass es natürlich schwer ist– oder ich glaube nicht, sondern ich weiß, dass es schwer ist –,Dass ein bisschen den Ruf der Vergangenheit auszuräumen. Es gab Probleme, es gab Probleme im Fernsehen, es gab auch Übergriffe, es gab auch Aktionen bei Auswärtsspielen und so weiter. Da muss man aber schon fragen, die liegen acht, neun, zehn Jahre zurück, wenn nicht sogar noch weiter. Deswegen würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass es ohne Fanprobleme gibt. Was natürlich immer auch so einen Aufstieg und so ein größeres Interesse mit sich bringt, ist eben, dass noch mehr Leute sich im Stadion tun, vielleicht auch Leute, die man nicht unbedingt da haben möchte. Aber dass es anderen Vereinen ähnlich geht. Ohne zum Beispiel da vielleicht noch eine Aktion herauszuheben, das war, ich glaube, im letzten Frühjahr, da hat tatsächlich, das ist der D-Block, das ist der Heimblock. Es gibt auch so ein Fanfach, Dachverband D-Block, wo sich verschiedene Gruppierungen untereinander sammeln. Die haben einmal ein ganz klares Statement rausgegeben und da war ich selber von überrascht, weil ich das nicht mitbekommen hatte. Es gab wohl einen Übergriff im Block oder ja, anzügliche Bemerkungen und so weiter. Und da hat sich der Block ganz klar positioniert und gesagt, wir verurteilen das, das hat bei uns in der Kurve nichts zu tun und so weiter. Und das hat es halt in der Vergangenheit eigentlich so nicht gegeben. Das war für mich schon so ein Zeichen, dass auch die Fans jetzt realisieren, dass natürlich nicht nur die Aufmerksamkeit auf dem SSV Ulm größer ist, sondern auch die Aufmerksamkeit auf der Fanszene.
Damit haben wir das doch auch eingeordnet. Ich wollte da eben mal eine Einordnung von möglichst nahe dran, denn auch das habe ich halt nur mitbekommen. Wie es denn immer so ist, weiß man nicht, was davon dann überspitzt sein könnte, was davon hängen bleibt, wann das genau ist. Man kriegt nur Tendenzen mit. Deswegen vielen lieben Dank dafür die Einordnung. Das hilft natürlich auch total. Und dann können wir auch langsam zum Endliche leiten. Mona, Nadine, vielen Dank für eure Zeit. Wenn ich jetzt nichts vergessen habe, dann oder ihr gretet schon mal dazwischen, wenn irgendein Punkt nicht aufgekommen ist, den ihr unbedingt besprochen haben wollt. Wenn nicht, schweigt für immer. Gut, ich glaube, dann haben wir es. Dann bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch zu sagen, vielen lieben Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit in dieser Folge. Vielen lieben Dank für alle UnterstützerInnen dieses Podcasts. Da, wie gesagt, nochmal natürlich auch die Erwähnung, www.rasenfunk.de slash-supportersclub ist eure Adresse. Das ermöglicht nicht nur, dass Max das hauptberuflich machen kann, sondern ermöglicht auch, dass zum Beispiel Eva oder auch ich hier freiberuflich mit dazusteuern können, dass so viele Formate am Leben erhalten bleiben können und dass sich immer weiter aufbaut und der Rasenfunk bald hier irgendwie die Sportlandschaft prägt. Also vielen lieben Dank und bis zum nächsten Mal. Macht's gut, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.